it's pft ot thursday edition some things
we didn't get to when we had two full
hours to talk football on nbcsn and
there's a topic chris that we we had
planned to address but uh we sort of ran
out of time throughout the course of the
time that we were on tv and that relates
to
a trio of
soon-to-be third-year quarterbacks who
were all first-round picks in 2018 lamar
jackson the last guy taken in the first
round that year the only of the five
first round quarterbacks who clearly
clearly is no brainer shortlist
franchise quarterback josh rosen kind of
forgotten in miami i wouldn't be
surprised if he got traded somewhere
else now that they have two of tonga
viloa but three other guys that were
taken in round one baker mayfield first
overall sam darnold third overall josh
allen seventh overall you could say the
jury's still kind of out on those guys
kind of on a couple of them may i don't
know that's why we're talking about it
let's let's look at those three and
let's start with josh allen the only one
of the three who's actually made it to
the playoffs i don't view it as a make
or break year for josh allen i think
he's done enough to kind of secure his
future with the bills they traded up to
get him they were craving a franchise
quarterback i think they believe in him
and i think when we look at all the
things they're doing to make the offense
better they are trying to help him get
to his ceiling wherever his ceiling may
be
yeah you know i'm with you you know i'm
not so sure
you know any of these are quite make or
break years but certainly you know
between baker mayfield josh allen and
sam donald i think there is more
pressure on those three to like what you
mentioned lamar jackson and i would say
out of those three yeah i'm with you
mike i think josh allen has the least
amount of pressure on him as compared to
sam darnold or baker mayfield you know
josh allen won i mean we've seen special
attributes from this player whether it
was the running with the football was
rookie year where he did like some
michael vick type thing statistically
and then last year you know to bring his
team to the playoffs and he did refine
his game a little bit he was more
accurate and a better pass or was it
perfect no
but you know he went to the playoffs and
you know i think you know we're a little
bit prisoners in the moment you know we
remember some of the craziness that
happened at the end of that wild card
game in the houston texans game but
let's not forget buffalo was in the lead
because of great things josh allen had
done in the previous three quarters he
made some special plays to give them
cushion and put them in a position of
power against the sean watson and the
houston texans let alone he did it last
year with what i would call what is a
very average group of skill guys around
him uh to accentuate his talent so i'm
with you mike i mean i think josh allen
has shown he's on the right trajectory
and probably has the least amount of
pressure out of any of these guys on him
going into 2020.
he's got the rocket arm he's got the
running ability that it felt like at
times last year they were trying to keep
under wraps to keep him healthy we
thought he would get unleashed in the
playoffs and he did in that playoff game
he had some big running yards but that
boneheaded mistake that desire like
jameis winston has to make something
happen when nothing's there that's the
one area where they need to work on him
to get him to understand throw the ball
away take a seat don't do that thing
where you're trying to be superman and
save the day all by yourself it's not
going to work and i think that's one of
the reasons they're getting more help
because
you're less likely to have to be
superman if you've got the justice
league around you is that the right one
the justice league is with superman in
the event yeah you're right you're right
yes i don't know yes um all right let's
go to baker mayfield then baker mayfield
was
arguably the best of all of the 2018
first round quarterbacks based on his
rookie season he started the earliest i
think he played the most he played the
best
even though lamar jackson made it to the
playoffs he got involved late in the
season but mayfield regressed last year
he regressed horribly last year his
numbers last year were so bad and i
don't know how much of it was freddy
kitchens i don't know how much of it was
baker mayfield but now that kevin
stefanski is there what kind of heat is
on mayfield to really live up to that
number one overall pick in the draft
status that he entered with chris
i i think that
i mean baker mayfield has the most
pressure on him
of anybody you know one because i think
like you know to to to the point you
made his rookie year
he kind of set a a high bar and a
standard to where we go whoa we we see
some greatness there man this guy can do
some special things i'm excited about it
and then last year hey there was a lot
of errand throws and bad decisions and
head scratching moments to where you
just went man where did where did rookie
year baker mayfield go added the fact
that and baker mayfield's case or his
scenario you know there's no excuse for
lack of weapons i mean it's arguably you
could argue it's the cream of the crop
as far as weapons are concerned around a
young quarterback in football or any
quarterback in football when you talk
about the two running backs they have
the tight ends they got now the
offensive line they have we know obj and
jarvis landry so this to me and along
with being the number one pick in the
draft i think baker mayfield has more
pressure on him than anybody as far as
those uh draft picks that we saw the
five go in the first round a few years
back
yeah and look here's the thing
with a new coach and we see this all the
time new gm wants his own coach new
coach wants his own quarterback and
kevin stefanski comes in and kevin's and
look if we're having the conversation
about matt lafleur and aaron rodgers
right i think we can have the
conversation about kevin stefanski and
baker mayfield and i look at it this way
if mayfield
in stefanski's estimation just isn't
getting it done he's got case keenum
there
and keenum has already proven to
stefanski he can get it done because
stefanski was with keenum in minnesota
when they went on a tear and they ended
up in the nfc championship game and
keenum was awesome that year keenum was
so good that year i thought the vikings
should have kept him at 18 million and
not signed kirk cousins at 28 that's how
good keenum was and if if mayfield gives
stefanski a reason or if there's an
injury or anything that gives keenum an
opening
all bets are off at that point if keenum
plays like he did in 2017 now there's no
guarantee he's going to but there's a
different dynamic there with a new head
coach and uh i look this is the ultimate
incentive for mayfield we saw how he
played last year when the browns had all
the hype and when there was a sense that
mayfield was on the verge of being a
true franchise quarterback he regressed
now the heat's on him a little bit and i
think he needs to realize the heat's on
i mean he needs to change his ways on
the field and off the field and get to
his ceiling wherever his ceiling is
that's what this is all about with all
these guys get them to their ceiling
mate is moving in that direction after
2018 he took a big step back last year
and the coach is going to have ideas for
how he gets to his ceiling if he buys in
and makes that progress he's golden if
he doesn't
then
look it's not like the browns aren't
accustomed to changing quarterbacks
they know how that works and it's not
like they're going to stick with baker
mayfield longer than they should just
because they use the first overall pick
in the draft to get him chris
no
you're exactly right and listen they i
don't think we addressed even like hey
the pressure around him because of
getting obj the ball you've said that a
lot you know you think that that was
somewhat of the the downfall of the
browns offense or baker mayfield's
development was the fact that he felt
that pressure to get obj the ball and
that is real you know i know i've talked
about that with you before when i first
threw the joey galloway i was so nervous
every time i threw to joey because i
just wanted every ball to be perfect and
him to like me as a quarterback and you
know like catching my footballs and my
spirals and everything and i it added
more pressure to the situation you know
eventually i got used to it and i became
friends with joey and then i'm like okay
hey he's just joey galloway big deal i
don't think baker mayfield's gotten to
that
aspect or that part of the relationship
yet where he was totally comfortable
with obj plus we didn't see obj 100
healthy that was certainly an issue plus
you had a head coach it was a little you
know in over his head a little bit and
the one thing i'll say about the
stefanski conversation i think it's
really good for baker mayfield in this
aspect you know they're running the ball
is going to be the number one thing for
this team in this offense we just saw us
the fancy came from minnesota that's
what they want to do that's why they
signed jack coughlin that's why they you
know drafted jedrick wills jr with the
ninth pick in the draft because i think
they realize they have something special
in nick chubb they got a guy in baker
mayfield who could be very good in play
action and bootleg passes and stuff like
that and i think that could make the
game a little bit easier on baker
mayfield this year where last year there
was just moments where i went it's too
pass happy you're a good running team
why are we in the shotgun you know seven
plays in a row and doing this and it
became a little bit too much about the
pass game and baker and obj and jarvis
landry and i think it took away and put
more pressure on baker mayfield but took
away some of the strengths of that
brown's offense
and you know the point you make about
beckham and mayfield let's let's take a
step back and remember what was going on
in cleveland after the 2018 season
mayfield is at that point the new star
in cleveland right everyone's been
waiting for the next lebron in cleveland
they thought it was maybe going to be
johnny manziel who was there with
lebron's seal of approval that didn't
work now mayfield
re re energizes the franchise takes them
to the brink of the playoffs and it's
baker mayfield baker mayfield baker
mayfield oh and here comes obj right
just as mayfield is getting comfortable
being the guy in cleveland there's
another guy and i remember thinking at
the time is cleveland big enough to have
two superstars on the football team and
i just think there was always something
there there was always that tension
there was always that pressure every
week how are we going to get the ball to
obj we got to get the ball to obj obj
has to have the ball that's not the way
it should be it should be the
quarterback is in charge and he throws
to the open receiver and the receiver's
job is to get open shut his mouth catch
the ball and if you don't get the ball
thrown your way don't come back and
complain about it don't make it a point
of contention all week long during press
conferences i throw to the guy who's
open and if you don't like it get open
that's what should have happened last
year and i think that constant heat on
mayfield to satisfy obj
contributed to mayfield being dragged
down from what he was in 2018. uh mike i
don't disagree with anything you said
there i mean there's a lot you know
these are you know the mental aspects
that a franchise quarterback has to deal
with and juggle and overcome and be
mentally strong so that's a very real
aspect and listen i also think baker
mayfield brought a lot of pressure on
himself you know last offseason he went
on a commercial tour like he was peyton
manning a four-time mvp of football you
know you couldn't watch anything in
sports without seeing one or two baker
mayfield commercials during a break
that's going to put pressure on you too
because people and especially people
around the nfl are going to start
looking look at this kid thinks he's a
star i think he already thinks he
already made it because you know had
some had a little success as a as a
rookie and i think you know the media
and he gets blown up by everything oh my
gosh we have a star he's great he's
great he's great and then as soon as you
falter a little bit we start to pick you
apart a little bit and look at the
things of where you might have gone
wrong so yeah it's a it's a delicate
situation i don't know about you mike
but i do have the faith in these guys as
far as obj and jarvis landry and baker
mayfield that they have the type of dna
to get this right and and make this
thing successful i i believe that so
we'll see we'll see when it comes comes
time
brown's fans have been waiting for a
long time they definitely deserve it and
here's hoping that they can get it
turned in the right direction it's not
going to be easy though in the division
that has lamar jackson and the ravens
ben rothersburg and the steelers and now
joe burrow and the cincinnati bengals
one more guy taken in round one of the
2018 draft where i think he's the one of
the three where the jury is still out
sam darnold with the jets in part
because i'm still not sure that's the
guy adam gase would have wanted right
darnold the guy they traded up from
number six number three to get the
savior of the franchise the first
franchise quarterback they hoped since
joe namath
you know last it's just hard to tell i i
feel like adam gase is cursed when it
comes to his quarterbacks from ryan
tannehill getting injured to sam darnold
getting mono right at the beginning of
the season but this year for gay sanford
donald they got to find a way to make it
work because if it falls apart i think
they both could be gone after this year
uh no doubt and you know i think they
did a good job in the draft again got
him a big time left tackle got denzel
mims in the second round you know
brashad perryman and free agency josh
doxon in free agency some value signings
there
but i agree with like the first thing
you said mike i don't think we really
know sam darnold yet like i saw
improvement from him last year certainly
did towards the end of the year and i
like a lot of things about his game but
you know
we haven't seen him really play the
competitive part of the schedule yet you
know last year because of mono the
season was basically over by the time he
came back and became the starter right
they were they hadn't won a game and
then he came back in and they beat the
dallas cowboys but they were already in
such a deep hole that to me the pressure
was off it was off it was like oh this
is a lost season let's just continue to
try to fight and be competitive and
build something i think you could say
the same thing with year one year one
right he had the little foot injury
right when the season's about to get
competitive in the middle of the meat
and potatoes of the schedule
and he got to avoid that pressure of
that season as well so then he got to
come in at the end of the year and he
looked good but the games didn't mean
anything so i still do question sam
darnold i like what i see i just haven't
you know we haven't seen him play the
what i want to say the meat and potatoes
of the schedule to know what he's really
made of and when the pressure's on and
oh we're in the playoff run and we have
to win these type of games you know i
just i haven't seen sam darnold in that
environment yet and i think that's
probably the last piece of the puzzle i
need to see
difficult first half of the schedule
last year for the jets ridiculously
difficult and i wish i had paid closer
attention to that before foolishly
predicting the jets to make it to the
postseason but they finished six and two
i mean we used to get all jazzed up
about
teams that finish strong well they
finished six and two the falcons
finished six and two it'll be
interesting to see what they can carry
over all right before we go chris you
may have noticed this on your cell phone
device or maybe you did not in
cincinnati the effort to trade andy
dalton has concluded
in a failure to trade him he has been
released by the bengals which
not a surprise not a shock at all joe
burrow is their guy the bengals avoid 17
million dollars in cash obligation to
dalton and he's on the market now he's
available would it have been better to
be available earlier
probably just like with cam newton and
carolina but he's free and clear he'll
be available and now just like with cam
newton just like with joe flacco we got
to figure out where the hell these guys
are going to land for 2020 if anywhere
well i i the first thing i think of with
andy dalton is to reunite with jay
gruden who drafted him and jay gruden's
the offensive coordinator in
jacksonville right now and you know we
know they have gardner minshew but he's
still a little bit of a question mark
and an unproven commodity to where that
might be a place i would look you know
you know there's a veteran guy that
knows the offense and if gardner menchu
you know craps down his leg as for lack
of a better word uh more than you're
dead or does both sides
or appease the bed whatever it may be
then you have a guy like andy dalton to
come in and save the day but you know i
do think andy dalton you know is going
to find a home to me
quicker than a cam newton because
he's not as threatening as cam newton
again like we've talked about cam
newton's the type of guy that's gonna
pyre's gonna walk up the field and go
damn why isn't he our starter he's
special andy dalton's not necessarily
going to have that effect
yeah i agree with you and he's not going
to walk through the door with
expectations to compete to be the
starter it's going to cost less to get
him and and look he's not that this is
where it's a curse to be as good as cam
newton is right if andy dalton was as
good as cam newton he'd have a hard time
finding another job too of course he
wouldn't have been cut possibly by the
bengals and they wouldn't have taken joe
burrow because they wouldn't have been
uh holding the first pick in the draft
because they wouldn't have stunk last
year anyway um i'm look i i'm thinking
of any connection i possibly can marvin
lewis currently isn't in the league he
was the head coach when andy dalton was
drafted so it's not like marvin lewis
could sign him mike zimmer was the
defensive coordinator in cincinnati for
the first few years of andy dalton's
tenure they're back up to kirk cousins
as sean mannion i
it's a different offensive philosophy
altogether but i'd kind of like andy
dalton
has a different set of eyes and ears for
kirk cousins not not as a guy who you
would expect to play but just as a guy
who can help cousins
you know maybe see things he doesn't see
understand defensive concepts and
elevate his game mentally do you see any
merit to that
i do i definitely do you know i think
his skill set fits that offense there
too so that makes a lot of sense you
know my mind also went right away to
like the los angeles rams you know he's
going to fit what they do there having
just played under zach taylor's offense
he'll know that he could be a very good
backup for jared goff and then again i'm
going to go back to the pittsburgh
steelers you know the steelers view
themselves as a team that's a super bowl
contender do we want to take the chance
of big ben getting hurt again and going
down the same road we did last year to
have to invent offenses and win games
with their defense on a weekly basis so
right off the bat with a guy like andy
dalton i think of the teams who are in
wow we have a team right now that can
compete if we lose our quarterback can
we still compete and i think there's a
few out there that i would say no and
andy dalton certainly can bolster those
chances if you got him on your roster
and andy dalton ultimately had five
straight playoff appearances as the
starting quarterback of the bengals they
have fallen on hard times since then
they never won a playoff game under andy
dalton but still he was not a horrible
quarterback and i'm reminded of
a comment that was made in the in the
media
um
back before dalton was drafted out of
tcu in the second round in 2011.
a coach asked an unnamed coach asked a
member of the media back before the
draft has there ever been a red-headed
quarterback in the nfl who's really done
well it sounds idiotic but is there any
way that could be a factor we've
wondered that so uh yeah andy dalton has
done pretty well for himself despite the
color of his hair but that just shows
you how ridiculous this process can
ultimately be how about the uh a couple
of other possibilities houston texans
who have aj mccarron as the backup
kansas city chiefs with chad henney as
the backup tennessee titans logan
woodside is number two to ryan tannehill
there definitely i think that makes a
lot of sense i mean the tennessee titan
ones for sure i look at that and go that
makes sense that's smart you know i i
again i think there's going to be a big
mark
because i think there's too many of
these teams who who have underwhelming
quarterback situations
where this guy's going to be able to
help
so
uh you know i think those are a few good
ones that i would look at right off the
bat let alone i'm even the dallas
cowboys i'm thinking about andy dalton
you know you know
yeah and i'm trying to think about
somebody else i was gonna say atlanta
falcons i would i don't know what their
deal is with that job or what they're
trying to do but that would be another
team again that i feel like he could go
in and run that offense and if the
quarterback did get hurt they're not
going to fall off too much
how about blaine gabbard is to back up
to tom brady in tampa bay
well he's certainly going to make you
feel more comfortable right i mean
gabbard has done an okay job as a backup
but yes he's not andy dalton you know
yeah like you said mike we've kind of
disrespected andy dalton he's had a
better career that you know we want to
all give him credit for it just he's not
like a cream of the crop type
quarterback i think he's one of those
guys that if he's your starter you
always go he's good but we're looking
out of the corner of our eye
right now for somebody better that's the
kind of guy he is so
and i saw pete dim a little lighter
light of light us he uh texted us the
seattle seahawks you know that's a good
thought too i i still thought geno smith
was under contract up there but that
would make that would make sense if not
that andy dalton to go up there so their
season's not ruined if any if russell
wilson had a high ankle sprain or
something like that
yeah currently the depth chart on the
seattle seahawks roster at quarterback
is one russell wilson that's it so they
need somebody at some point and hey
maybe maybe they they were just waiting
for andy dalton i mean look we all knew
this was going to happen they weren't
going to be able to trade that salary
they're not going to pay part of the
salary the bengals aren't going to do
that to try to get a late round draft
pick next year they're going to cut him
they they will and now we see where he
lands next but i'm with you he's gonna
land somewhere before cam newton because
he's not a starter he doesn't have to
wait for that opportunity he'll be
someone's back up and uh he should
probably do fairly well that's it for
this thursday pft ot chris we'll check
out uh chris sims unbuttoned later today
the big effort making his return enjoy
your friday off we'll see you back on
monday everybody friday pft live big cat
we'll be back check us out around the
clock at profootballtalk.com and have a
great thursday
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports